[موسيقى]
مساء الخير تدخل القوى الخارجيه في الصراع
الذي اندلع في السودان منذ 15 ابريل
الماضي 2023 امر حتمي لا جدال في ذلك حتى
هذه اللحظه وانا اسجل هذه الحلقه عصر يوم
26 ابريل لا يوجد تدخل خارجي مؤثر في
الصراع الدائر كل الدول المهتمه بالسودان
وما اكثرها تراقب الموقف بقلق وتجري
عمليات احماء من خارج خطوط المواجهه في
انتظار اللحظه المناسبه للتدخل وتدخلها
سوف يتوقف على امد الصراع
وتطوراته او مالاته
لكن التدخل حتمي لا جدال في ذلك لماذا لان
السودان تمثل مصالح استراتيجيه مهمه جدا
لهذه الدول لا يمكن ان تغفل عنها او
تتراخى في حمايتها ماذا تمثل السودان
باختصار تمثل شريان الحياه اللي هو مياه
النيل لبلد مثل مصر تمثل الامن الغذائي
لكثير من دول العالم وعلى راسها دول
الخليج التي استثمرت مليارات الدولارات في
زراعه الاراضي السودانيه تمثل استقرار
الملاحه العالميه من خلال السفن التي تمر
امام سواحلها الطويله في البحر الاحمر
تمثل مصدر لثروات طبيعيه كثيره مهمه
الحديث يتركز هذه الايام على الذهب لكن
ثروات الطبيعيه للسودان لا تقتصر على
الذهب كل هذه فوائد الدول التي تتعامل مع
السودان تسعى لتامينها والحفاظ عليها لكن
هذا جانب واحد الجانب الثاني الاخطار
والتهديدات التي يمكن ان تلحق بهذه الدول
الدول اللي معنيه بالامر السوداني امام
احد سيناريوهين السيناريو الاول ان تنفلت
الاوضاع اكثر مما هي منفلته الان لا قدر
الله وبالتالي تتحول السودان الى
مصدر للهجره غير الشرعيه والجريمه المنظمه
والارهاب والفوضى وتغرق المنطقه كلها في
يعني فوضى وتتهدد مصالح كل هذه الدول هذا
امر يقلق كل الدول لكن في دول اخرى لا
تقلق فقط من الفوضى بل تقلق من استقرار
السودان تحت حكم نظاما قد لا يراعي
مصالحها كلنا راينا مثلا في السنوات
الماضيه كيف تاثرت مصالح دول الخليج تحت
حكم عمر البشير او في بعض سنوات
حكم عمر البشير الذي كانت لديه تقلبات
كثيره عندما تحالف مع الايرانيين على حساب
المصالح الخليجيه كلنا راينا كيف تضررت
الحكومه المصريه او مصر من تحالف وتقارب
عمر حسن البشير مع اثيوبيا ضد المصالح
المصريه كلنا راينا كيف اثارت السودان
قلق العالم بعد ان فتح عمر حسن البشير
ابواب السودان لجماعات اسلاميه كثير منها
متطرف متشدد ومطلوب من انظمه دول اخرى
وعلى راس هذه الجامعات التي استقبلها كانت
القاعده واسامه بن لادن وقيادات القاعده
وعليه فان السودان لكل هذه الاسباب يمثل
حاجز كبير في يعني رؤوس صناع القرار في
كثير من دول المنطقه والعالم
الحلقه دي احنا بنحاول نجاوب فيها على
سؤال يشغل الراي العامل الان اين تقف دول
العالم المختلفه من الصراع الدائر وفي اي
معسكر تقف الكلام كله بيتركز على الامارات
ومصر وروسيا لكن ايضا بيتناول السعوديه
دول الخليج المختلفه الولايات المتحده
اسرائيل
اثيوبيا تشاد ليبيا الى اخره علشان نقدر
نعرف مواقف اهم هذه الدول ومتى يمكن ان
تتدخل بشكل واضح في الصراع الدائر علينا
اولا ان نبدا بالف باء سودان وما هو الف
باء سوداء لمن لا يعرف السودان الف باء
سودان بيقول لنا ان السودان هذا البلد
العربي الافريقي المهم مساحته نحو واحد
وتسعه من عشره مليون كيلو متر مربع اي
تقريبا ضعف مساحه مصر اللي مساحتها مليون
كيلو متر مربع اي تعادل مساحه المانيا
وفرنسا وايطاليا واسبانيا مجتمعه
وهذه الدوله ذات المساحه الكبيره هي ثالث
اكبر دوله في افريقيا من حيث المساحه بعد
الجزائر والكونغو لديها اطلاله كبيره على
البحر الاحمر اكثر من 850 كيلو مترا البحر
الاحمر هذا واحد من اهم شرايين الملاحه
الدوليه في العالم لانه جنوبه باب المندب
شماله
قناه السويس وبيعبر في هذا المجرى الملاحي
المهمه اكثر من 10% من التجاره على سطح
هذه الكره الارضيه
السودان عنده سبع دول
متصله مباشره
بحدوده البريه السبع دول ديت هي مصر
وليبيا وتشاد وجنوب السودان واريتريا
واثيوبيا
وافريقيا الوسطى كل ما يجري في السودان لا
يبقى في السودان ولكن ينزاح وتتاثر بهذه
الدول بشكل مباشر يمكن ايضا ان تضاف الى
دول الجوار كل دول الجزيره العربيه على
اعتبار ان دول الجزيره العربيه السعوديه
اليمن باقي دول الخليج
بتتشاطئ مع السودان في
البحر الاحمر اما وقد قلنا ذلك نعود الى
الموضوع
لكن قبل ما نتكلم على مواقف في الدول اهم
الدول اللي هي يعني نشطه في الصراع في
السودان او مهتمه بما يجري في السودان علي
ان اذكركم اولا ان الموقف العام لكل دول
العالم المواقف الرسميه كل دول المنطقه كل
دول العالم كلها متمسكه بانها على الحياد
وانها لا تتدخل في الشان السوداني وانها
لن تتدخل في الشان السوداني وانها على
مسافه واحده من كل الاطراف وانها راغبه في
تهدئه الاوضاع من خلال وساطه بعد هذه
الدول صادق مؤقتا لكن لا تصدق ابدا اي
دوله تقول انها لا تتدخل في الشان الداخلي
لدوله ما كل الدول اما بتتدخل او بتسعى
للتدخل
او سوف تتدخل في لحظه ما هددت مصالحها لكن
مره اخرى حتى هذه اللحظه بعض الدول
الصادقه لانها تعتقد ان هي انت ريست قليلا
ربما ينتهي الصراع الدائر الى صالحها دون
الحاجه الى التدخل نبدا بمين نبدا بمصر
ليه بمصر لانها اكثر المهتمين اكثر
المستفيدين اكثر المتضررين مما يحدث في
السودان
باعتبارات واضحه اولا في حدود مباشره اكثر
من 1200 كيلو
اثنين انه
مياه النيل اللي هو شريان الحياه لمصر
بيعبروا السودان الى اراضيها دايما مصر
حريسه اولوياتها وخطوطها الحمراء في
السودان ان تكون الحكومه الموجوده على راس
السلطه هناك متفهمه للسواغل المصريه امنها
القومي امنها المائي لا تريد حكومه ابدا
تسعى لعرقله وصول مياه النيل الى اراضيها
كيف يمكن ان تعرق المياه النيل بانها
تقييم سدود على مياه النيل بان هي تنحاز
الى اثيوبيا في صراعها مع مصر حول مياه
النيل كما هو حادث منذ سنوات فيما يتعلق
بصد النهضه
مصر لديها شواغل اخرى في اي حكومه تاتي
الى السودان الا تكون هذه حكومه مناوئه
كما حدث لسنوات طوال حكم عمر حسن البشير
فتاوي جماعات معارضه خصوصا عندما اوى
جماعات الاسلاميه اخوان وغير اخوان واتهم
في فتره من الفترات بانها حاول او الضلعه
او شارك في محاوله اغتيال الرئيس المصري
الاسبق حسني مبارك هي قلقه ايضا من اي
اضطرابات تحدث في السودان لان هذا يعني
امرين الامر الاول موجات من الهجره ترهق
الاقتصاد المصري المرهق بالفعل مصر فيها
حوالي 5 مليون سوداني يمكن ان يتضاعف هذا
الرقم اذا تطهور الوضع لا قدر الله الى ما
هو اسوا
اثنين هذه الاضطرابات قد تهدد الملاحه
البحريه في البحر الاحمر فيتاثر تتاثر
الحركه في قناه السويس احد اهم موارد
الاقتصاد المصري طبعا بديهي ان الاضطرابات
قد تؤدي الى نشاط جامعات ارهابيه تسلل
عناصر اجراميه الى حدودها كل هذه شواغل
للدوله المصريه فيما يتعلق بالسودان
بالاضافه للمصالح الاقتصاديه المفهومه بين
اي دولتين متجاورتين
مصر عندها من متابعه خطابها السياسي
وتحركاتها واضح انه اذا كان عليها ان تقف
في احد المعسكرين فالواضح ان هي تفضل
معسكر القوات المسلحه السودانيه كان هذا
واضحا ليس فقط بعد اندلاع الصراع في 15
ابريل الماضي ولكن منذ سقوط حكومه الرئيس
عمر حسن البشير في 11 ابريل 2019 قصه
طويله لكن باختصار انه الدوله المصريه
شافت ان القوى اللي موجوده والمؤثره والتي
تتصدر المشهد بعد سقوط عمر حسن البشير
ثلاثه قوه اثنين منهم عسكريتين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه
ثم قوات الدعم السريع بقياده الفريق ديجلو
او حميدتي
وقوى مدنيه تحت مظله كبيره سميت بقوى
التغيير القوه الحريه والتغيير
وهذه القوه بتتالف من يعني
نقابات مهنيه
واحزاب سياسيه وبعض الحركات العسكريه
السابقه التي كانت بتطحن بتطمح فيه الحصول
على نصيبي من السلطه والسلطه والثروه في
السودان
اجمالا مصر باختصار لم تشعر ابدا
بالارتياح ولا الرغبه في التعامل معه
للقوه المدنيه اللي اطاحت بعمر حسن البشير
ولا بالتعامل مع قوات الدعم السريع بقياده
حبيتي وفضلت التعامل منذ البدايه مع
القوات المسلحه السودانيه بقياده الفريق
برهان لماذا اولا فيما يتعلق بالقوه
المدنيه نظره الدوله المصريه وتشاركها في
ذلك بصراحه وبوضوح دول اخرى في المنطقه زي
السعوديه وزي الامارات اللي هي متصدره
المشهد الان
بتاخذ على هذه القوه المدنيه امرين الامر
الاول ان هي بتعتبر ان هذه القوه بتتحدث
عن قضايا الديمقراطيه والحريه الى اخره
ودي وهذه الدول لا تنظر بكثير من الارتياح
الى هذا النوع من المطالبات وبتعتبره ان
رفاهيه لا تتحملها دوله يعني
بتعيش على كف عفريت حققوا الاستقرار الاول
حققوا الانضباط حققوا التنميه الاقتصاديه
ثم تحدثت عن الديمقراطيه وبصراحه
الديمقراطين ليست من اولويات الحكومات
العربيه اللي موجوده الاكثر من كده انها
بتنظر الى هذه القوى اللي هي بترفع شعار
الديمقراطيه والحريات بكثير من الريبه
وبتعتبرها ان هي عناصر قليله الخبره وان
هي ربما اسوا من ذلك ان هم بيمثلوا قوى
اخرى بتعمل على تفتيت هذه الدول اما نتيجه
سذاجتهم او نتيجه ان هم بيعملوا مع دول
اخرى لا تريد خيرا لهذه الدوله
الاخطر من كل داء هم بينظروا للقوه
المدنيه على انها خليط من قوه كثيره جدا
ليس لها يعني قوه واحده تلتف حولها لا
توجد قوه مركزيه فيهم تستطيع ان تخاطبها
اعدادهم كبيره منقسمين على انفسهم
وانقسموا بالفعل على انفسهم زي ما شفنا
قوى الحريه والتغيير الى معسكرين رئيسيين
وداخل المعسكرين الرئيسيين فيهم توجهات
كثيره باختصار مصر دول الخليج دول اخرى في
المنطقه بتنظر ببساطه شديده بمزيج من
الازدراء وعدم الثقه في هذه القوى المدنيه
يبدو تذكر هذه الدول مصر الامارات
السعوديه
بثوار
يناير 2011 في مصر اللي يعني
الدوله في مصر لا تنظر اليهم بكثير من
الثقه وبتعتبر انه هم وكل الجامعات
المشابهه لهم في الدول العربيه اللي
تسيدوا المشهد في الربيع العربي لم يجلبوا
الا خرابا على كل الاحوال انا لا اقول لك
هذا صح او خطا انا اقول لك كيف تنظر
الحكومات الى هذه القوى المدنيه والقوه
الثوريه
اثنين فيما يتعلق بقوات الدعم السريع من
الاول المسؤولين المصريين نظروا بعين
الريبه الى الفريق حميدتي وقوات الدعم
السريع لكن كانوا مضطرين للتعامل معه
باعتباره جزء من المؤسسات والقوى اللي
موجوده في السودان لكنهم لم يثقوا فيه
لماذا لم يثقوا فيه واحد بدايه هو
بيعتبروه زعيم ميليشيا وليس ضابط قوات
مسلحه او مجرد ضبط قوات مسلحه يطمح في
السلطه بل زعيم ميليشيا وهم لم يستوعبوا
فكره التفاوض مع زعيم ميليشيا الطامح في
الوصول الى راس السلطه في السودان
اثنين وهو الاخطر ان الفريق حمدتي
بدا اولا هو عنده امبراطوريه التجاريه
متشعب العلاقات الخارجيه بشكل يصعب
السيطره عليه ويصعب الثقه في من وجهه نظر
بعد المسؤولين المصريين اعطيكم ثلاث امثله
علاقات قويه جدا مع الروس علاقات قويه مع
الاسرائيليين علاقات قويه مع الاثيوبيين
والعلاقات الثلاثه مصدر للقلق المصري طب
ما المشكله ان يكون له علاقه مع الروس على
سبيل المثال العلاقه المصريه والروسيه
علاقات ممتازه ايوه علاقات ممتازه لكن هذا
لا يعني ان مصر ترحب بطرف سوداني مستعد
لان يمدح الروس قاعده عسكريه على بعد 400
500 كم من الحدود المصريه مصر كانت رافضه
ان تحصل صديقتها روسيا على قاعده عسكريه
لا في ليبيا ولا في السودان ولا في اي
منطقه بتعدها مصر منطقه مجال حيوي لها
مش عاوزه دوله كبيره يبقى عندها قاعده
عسكريه يمكن ان تهددها يمكن ان تقيد من
حركتها في اقليمها او في مجالها الحيوي
نجحت في ان هي تحبط الطلب الروسي في فتره
من الفترات لكن علمت ان الفريق حمدي قد
اعطى وعدل للروس بانه ان جاء الى يعني
تولى مقاليد السلطه في السودان فهو مستعد
لان يمنحهم هذا الطلب الذي يسعى اليه
الروس منذ سنوات طويله وعندنا حلقه
اتكلمنا فيها عن القصه دي استاذنكم ان
تعودوا اليها حتى لا نكرر ما جاء فيها
الروست بيحلموا بقاعده على البحر الاحمر
منذ سنوات فشلوا في تحقيق هذا الحلم من
خلال اقامه قاعده لهم في جيبوتي تحت
الضغوط الغربيه على جيبوتي وبدا يسعى
للحصول على قاعده بديله في السودان ولكن
هذا الحلم تعثر حتى الان لعده اسباب منهم
التحفظ
ومصر واحده من دول ترفض الولايات المتحده
الغرب طبعا
يرفضون الامر الثاني علاقته الحميمه
باسرائيل
لانه صحيح ان مصر عندها علاقات سلام مع
اسرائيل لكنها تعتبر ان هذه العلاقات
علاقه او العلاقات السلام مع اسرائيل
علاقات تمت بحكم الامر الواقع وتحت
الضروره القصوى
لكنها لا تتمنى ان تسعى دول المنطقه
الاخرى لعلاقات السلام والاسوا من السلام
التطبيع يعني اذا كان ولابد من سلام يكون
جيد لكن لا يكون علاقات حميمه تسمح
لاسرائيل بالتغلغل في كل الدول التي تحيط
بمصر وبالتالي تهدد مصالحها وتضغط عليها
والعلاقات بين حمتي واجهزه الدوله في
اسرائيل قويه وخصوصا الموساد وبينهم تعاون
امني واستخباراتي على مستوى لا يخفى على
احد ثلاثه علاقات حميدتي المهمه والقويه
برئيس الوزراء ابي احمد
وهو خصم لدود للدوله المصريه بسبب
مشروعاته الطموحه اللي ترى مصر انها تهدد
مصالحها وخصوصا في ايامها النيل الفريق
حميدتي الاخبار متواتره من مصادر محترمه
بان لديه استثمارات بمليارات الدولارات في
اثيوبيا وانه اقرب الى وجهه نظر
الاثيوبيين في اهميه اقامه سد النهضه
ويعتقد مع الاثيوبيين ان هذا لن يضر
السودان اما مصرف فيعني معارضتها يعني
ليست اولويه بالنسبه للفريق
الاوضاع اكثر واكثر طبعا بانه في بدايه
الصراع يوم 15 ابريل الماضي سواء عن قصد
او عن خطا والارجح انه عن خطا من بعض
رجاله يعني انهم
قوات مصريه كانت موجوده في مطار مروي
الامر الذي سبب احراجا وضغطا على السلطات
المصريه لهذه الاسباب مجتمعه
فمصر من البدايه هي تفضل التعامل مع
القوات المسلحه السودانيه اذا كان ولابد
من ان يكون هناك صف واحد اما اذا كان هناك
اختيار وامكن تسويه الاوضاع في ظل ان
القوات المسلحه المصريه المسلحه السودانيه
هي المسيطره فافضل هذا لمصر وللسودان اذا
كان ولابد من طرف واحد فالحكومه المصريه
من الواضح جدا انها اخذت موقف الجيش
السوداني ضد قوات الدعم السريع وتستطيع ان
يعني تعرف ذلك ببساطه حتى من الخطاب
الاعلامي في وسائل الاعلام المصريه اللي
بتصف قوات الدعم السريع بالميليشيا
هذا عن مصر طيب ماذا عن الامارات بالنسبه
للامارات اللي بيكثر الحديث عليها هي دوله
نشطه طبعا في دول كثيره وعندها طموحات
بتذكرنا بالطموحات القطريه بعد الربيع
العربي وقبل القطيعه اللي تمت بينها وبين
اربع دول في 2017 وانتهت في 2021
تقدر تقول كده انه الامارات زي دول
الخليجيه اخرى عندها مجموعه من المصالح في
السودان واحد الاراضي الخصبه اللي
استاجرتها او اللي اشتريتها بمليارات
الدولارات لتوفير الامن الغذائي
اذكركم ده رقم واحد اذكركم انه دول الخليج
دول غنيه نعم لكنها الدول صحراويه
لديها مصادر شهيحه من المياه لما حاولت
يكون عندها مشروعات زراعيه كما الحال
بالنسبه للسعوديه
اللي حاولت في وقت من الاوقات ان هي
تستزرع اراضيها بمحاصيل استراتيجيه زي
القمح وغيره وجدت ان التكلفه عاليه وفرص
النجاح ليست مبهره فبدات السعوديه
والامارات والكويت وقطر
بالمناسبه ودول اخرى زي الاردن زي مصر حتى
بداوا يطاردوا فرص الاستثمار الزراعي في
كل دول العالم امريكا اللاتينيه اسيا
افريقيا وكانت السودان واحده من هذه الدول
اذهبون يشترون اراضي او يستاجرونها
ويزرعونها بما شاؤوا من المحاصيل فيحققون
الامن الغذائي لشعوبهم وما يفيض يصدرونه
لدول العالم الاخرى في تحقيق اجراه صحفيا
وانا واضع لحضراتكم رابطه لموقع
اللي هو الموقع التحقيقات
الصحفيه الاستقصائيه المعروف
اجريا او نشر في 30 مايو 2019 واعتمد فيه
الصحفيان على بيانات تحتها موقع
وهو قاعده بيانات دوليه متخصصه في انتقال
ملكيه الاراضي من طرفا الى طرف على اعتبار
ان ملكيه الاراضي او الاراضي يعني اصل
شحيح او متناقص يعني في هذا الكوكب
تحقيق اعتمادا على بيانات ومواضع لحضراتكم
روابط التحقيق و روابط يمكن ان تتابعوها
بيقولوا ان الدول المختلفه في القلب منها
دول الخليج
استحوذت او اشترت منذ عام 1972 حتى تاريخ
نشر التحقيق في 2019 على
762 الف هكتار من الاراضي الصراعيه الخصبه
في السودان معظم هذه الاراضي تم بيعها
لهذه الدول مش لازم الدوله يعني حكومه
شركات في هذه الدول بعد عام 2000 ووفقا
لنفس التحقيق فان التفاوض جاري منذ 2019
على شراء ثلاثه واربعه من عشره مليون
هكتار اضافيه لمستثمرين وشركات وحكومات
سواء خليجيه او غير خليجيه تركيه مصر
الاردن سوريا دول اخرى
الضحى الاولى ودي مصلحه بتخص الامارات وزي
ما قلت لحضراتكم تخص الدول الاخرى المصلحه
الثانيه تخص الامارات وليس دول العالم
الاخرى وهي
الطموح الاماراتي في اداره اكبر عدد ممكن
من الموانئ حول العالم وعندهم طموح ان هم
يكونوا اكبر دوله في اداره التجاره
البحريه بالسيطره واداره اكبر عدد ممكن من
الموانئ في افريقيا في اسيا في اوروبا في
امريكا الى اخره وهذه قصه يعني معروفه
تحدثنا عنها وممكن ان اتحدث عنها ايضا
لاحقا مره اخرى
هي مؤخرا سعت الى الحصول على اكثر من
كونسيشن او اكثر من عقد يعني لتطوير موانئ
جديده ونجحت بالفعل في ديسمبر في الحصول
على موافقه السودانيين لاداره او لتطوير
ميناء ابو عمامه باستثمارات حوالي سته
مليار دولار
المصلحه الثالثه للامارات تخص الامارات
وحدها هي اهتمامها الكبير جدا بثروات
الذهب اللي موجوده في السودان وما سر
اهتمام الامارات بالذهب السوداني الامارات
مهتمه بالذهب في كل مكان في العالم لانها
منذ نحو 20 عاما قررت ان تكون اهم مركز
تجاره للذهب في العالم ونجحت في تحقيق ذلك
بشكل كبير واصبحت من اهم مراكز تجاره
الذهب حول العالم يعني في 2021 على سبيل
المثال صدرت الامارات وتحديدا دبي
ذهبا بحوالي 28.7 يعني نقول 29 مليار
دولار وده كان يعادل اكثر من 7% من كل
صادرات الذهب العالميه في نفس العام علشان
هي تصدر هذا الذهب هي لا تنتجه لازم
تستورده استوردته منين من مئه دوله حول
العالم من بينها السودان
واحده من اكبر منتجين الذهب في العالم
طيب
الذهب تحت سيطره مين في السودان الذهب تحت
سيطره الفريق حمدتي وبالتالي علاقتها
توثقت بالفريق حميدتي وبقوات الدعم السريع
اللي بيرقصها لانه هو صاحب اكبر عدد من
مناجم الذهب وفي القلب منها طبعا جبل عامر
اللي هو اهم مناجم الذهب هناك علاقتها
توثقت ايضا بالفريق حميتي لانها حين قررت
محاربه الحوثيين في 2015 استعانت
بالسودانيين بافراد من الجيش السوداني
وافراد من قوات الدعم السريعه وبالتالي
توثقت علاقتها بالقياده السودانيه في
الجيش وبقوات الدعم السريع لكن الدعم
السريع تعوله معها اعطى الاماراتيين حافزا
اضافيا بالاضافه للذهب لتوثيق علاقتها
بالفريق حمدتي بعد اقامتها لعلاقات مع
اسرائيل والتعاون الواسع بينها وبين
اسرائيل دخل حميتي على الخط فاصبحت هذه
العلاقات ايضا عاملا اضافيا لتوثيق
العلاقه بين الامارات وبين حميدتي وبين
اسرائيل
هذا اجمالا هي المصالح الاماراتيه اللي
موجوده في السودان في ميل في وسائل
الاعلام لتصوير الامر كما ان الامارات
تدفع دفعا بحمتي لحرب يقضي فيها على الجيش
السوداني هذا كلام غير منطقي هذه مصالح
الاماراتيين اعتقد ان مصلحتهم الاساسيه في
الحفاظ على هذه المصالح وليس في شخص حماتي
شخصيه حميتي توافقت مع الاماراتيين وكفرت
لهم مصالح حيويه مهمه تتمنى ان يستمر لكن
الافضل للامارات ان هي الان علاقتها جيده
القوات المسلحه السودانيه ان تستقر الامور
ربما اذا كانت الامور على هذا النحو واذا
كان لابد من معسكر واحد ونحن لم نصل الى
هذه المرحله فالامارات يبدو انها في صف
الفريق حميتي اكثر من صف القوات المسلحه
السودانيه خصوصا ان هناك اعتبار كان قائما
منذ سنوات وهو انه في السياسه الخارجيه
للامارات انها تعادي اي مؤسسه او اي منظمه
محسوبه على التيار الاسلامي وخصوصا تيار
الاخوان المسلمين
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه متهمه من داخل
السودان اكثر من خارج السودان بانها
مخترقه او مسيطر عليها من نظام البشير
القديم اللي هو جبهه الانقاذ او جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين لكن هذا الاختراق لا
يبدو انه مؤثر جدا الى الدرجه التي تدفع
الاماراتيين لمعاداه الجيش بدليل ان مصر
اللي عندها نفس الهدف وهي محاربه الاخوان
على علاقه طيبه
بالجيش السوداني
المصالح السعوديه هي زي مصالح باقي الدول
الخليج عندها استثمارات ضخمه في الاراضي
السودانيه لغايه 2015 انفقت السعوديه
حوالي 13 مليار دولار على شراء اراضي
سودانيه لاستذراعها بكل المحاصيل الاساسيه
محاصيل غذائيه اعلاف حيوانات
اعلاف حيوانيه
نباتات لانتاج الوقود الحيوي 13 مليار
دولار رقما ضخم كاستثمارات في اي بلد لكنه
يصبح ضخم جدا جدا في بلد صدرته حوالي
اربعه مليار دولار اللي هي السودان
والناتج المحلي الاجمالي له اقل من 36
مليار دولار سنويا
ايضا هي مهتمه به طبعا استقرار الملاحه في
البحر الاحمر ومهتمه باستقرار السودان حتى
لا تتواط حتى لا يصبح يعني مصدرا
للاضطرابات والفوضى الى اراضيها وهي
بتشاطؤ هي اقرب دول الخليج الى السودان
الموقف السعودي يبدو لي انه في هذه اللحظه
انه اكثر من اي دوله اخرى يتمنى فعلا انه
يقوم
بتهدئه الامور لانه عنده علاقات مع الجيش
وعنده علاقات مع حماتي كلاهما حارب
لصالحها الحوثيين في اليمن وكمان اللحظه
التي اندلع فيها الصراع دفعت السعوديين ان
يكونوا اكثر حيادا من غيرهم اللي هي الشهر
اللي بيسبق مؤتمر القمه العربي
لا تستضيفوا الرياض في 19 مايو المقبل سبق
الاعداد لهذه القمه رغبه سعوديه في تهدئه
الاوضاع في كل المنطقه علاقات افضل بتحسن
علاقتها مع سوريا بتحسن علاقتها مع تركيا
بتحسن علاقتها مع ايران طبعا عاوزه يبقى
في حاله استقرار ولا تريد لاضطرابات في
السودان ان تعكر هذا الاستقرار كمان عاوزه
هي تحصل على
يعني شهاده الجميع بانها نجحت فيما فشل
فيه الاخرون اي قادره على تحقيق التهدئه
والوساطه في ملفات شائكه في العالم العربي
خصوصا قبل مؤتمر القمه العربي في 19 مايو
المقبل هذا هو موقف المملكه كما يبدو حتى
لحظه تسجيل الحلقه لان الاحداث بتتسارع
والمواقف تتغير وبالتالي يمكن ان يتغير
موقف المملكه ممكن ان يتغير موقف الامارات
يتغير موقف مصر اللي احنا تحدثنا عنهم
باسهاب في هذه الحلقه
في الحلقه القادمه ان شاء الله سوف نخصصها
لمواقف الدول الاخرى خصوصا الدول الكبرى
والقوى الاقليميه المختلفه يعني روسيا
الصين الولايات المتحده الموقف الاسرائيلي
يستحق التوقف عنده مواقف دول الجوار مثل
تشاد وجنوب السودان كيف يمكن ان تتاثر
وكيف يمكن ان تؤثر في الصراع ومع الموقف
في السودان ان شاء الله تكون لنا حلقات
الاخرى اشكركم والى اللقاء